ليس غريبا على صدام
أن يقدم على تنفيذ قرارت جريئة
، لكن أن يقرر قتل رئيس دولة فهذا هو الغريب حقا،
الرؤساء يجتمعون في المغرب ليناقشوا القضايا
أما صدام فقد جاء ليقتل حافظ الأسد،
فما الذي جرى عندها وكيف كانت ردة فعل الملك المغربي
،للقصة بقية ،،
عندما يغضب صدام عليك ألا تقف في وجهه،
لكن بالمقابل عليك ألا تكون سببا لإغضابه
، ومن دون سابق إنذار وعند انعقاد القمة العربية في الرباط،
العاهل المغربي يبلغ الرئيس السوري حافظ الأسد
أن عليه تغيير مكان إقامته حيث يقيم الرؤساء
لأن صدام قرر قتله،
فهل يهرب الأسد خوفا على نفسه؟..
في الحقيقة فإن الأسد رفض الهروب وقرر مواجهة صدام،
وطلب التفاصيل حول العملية،
عندها تأكدت الاستخبارات المغربية من التفاصيل،
وأبلغته أن عملية اغتياله ستكون ليلا
وبواسطة ١٢ فردا أمرهم صدام بتفيذ المهمة
من فردين من ضباط الصاعقة العراقية،
وهناك وقفت المغرب حائرة بسبب هذه العملية
فما الذي سيحدث لو نجحت الحملية حقا؟
فقوة صدام تمنعهم من التدخل،
وعندما علم المقدم آصف شوكت المرافق الخاص بحافظ الأسد،
طلب من المخابرات المغربية
إخلاء الممر المؤدي إلى غرفة الأسد وعدم التدخل،
وطلب منهم توفير ٣ رشاشات مع الذخيرة،
وب٦ عناصر فقط قام شوكت بتدابرة للتصدي لمحاولة الاغتيال،
وكانت أوامر تقضي بعدم التحدث مع أي عراقي
سيأتي باتجاههم وإطلاق النار عليه فورا،
وعندما تقدم ٣ من عناصر فرقة الاغتيال باتجاه سلم الدرج
لاحظوا عنصرا وعلموا أنه من أفراد الحماية السورية،
فتراجعوا فورا،  وانسحبوا ليجدوا طريقا آخر،
عندها ذهب فرد المراقبة ليخبر آصف شوكت بالأمر
فتلقى ضربة حتى أسقطه شوكت أرضا
وقال ألم أأمركم بقتل من ترونه منهم فورا،
عد إلى مكانك حالا،
فسمع حوارهما أحد أفراد عملية الاغتيال
وعاد يخبر صدام
فأمرهم بإلغاء العملية،
لكن شوكت ظل واقفا مع رشاشه طوال الليل أمام غرفة حافظ الأسد،
وظل ليومين يحرسه دون أن يغفل للحظة واحدة،
وفي اليوم الثالث
في وقت الغداء نزل شوكت واتجه للمطعم
حيث يجتمع الرؤساء لتناول غدائهم،
وذهب محاولا ضرب مرافق صدام حسين في رأسه
لكن مرافق صدام كان ضابط صاعقة مفتول العضلات
ذو بنية جسدية قوية
فتصدى لشوكت وأوقعه أرضا،
عندها وضع آصف يده على مسدسه
ليخرجه لكن صدام أوقف مرافقه بإيمآت بعينيه
، فانتهت الحادثة على ذلك وبعد ذلك
غادر صدام الرباط عائدا لبلده،
وبقيت الحادثة سرية إلى يومنا هذا
فلم يفاخر بها صدام ولم يجرؤ حافظ الأسد على قولها،
وخرجت من القصر الملكي في المغرب،
فهل كان حافظ الأسد هو الرئيس الوحيد
الذي حاول صدام أن يقتله،
لمعرفة المزيد من مواقف صدام الحازمة ضد الحكام العرب
تابعونا على قناة شاهد لتعرف
ونرجوا تفعيل الاشتراك والجرس ليصلكم كل جديد،،،